when I went it down and I did the made
the sex robot of myself going down to
the factory that builds the sex dolls
because she's a sex doll body in a robot
head the dolls the number one request
from the guys buying sex dolls is they
wanted them to be heavier the technology
just isn't available yet here's a
problem thicker or heavier like thick
like a curvy now most guys like yeah
athletic curvy ya big fat yeah big
strong legs big ass small waist there's
nothing wrong with that it's fan time I
feel like what's in now is small boobs
big butt go to amis go to Graham amazing
lifters I feel like like body's why are
we going to lifters why show you are
lifting gay no these growths that are
old like like the first one there are
Invictus or this girl who lifts weights
look at her body for a second let go
good or go to her Instagram if she
wasn't lifting weights and you just saw
her in a bikini on the street yeah no
problem you can't keep going down keep
going she's pretty she's adorable
yeah and she's thick though she's a big
strong girl but I find no she's on
steroids Oh correct that would be anavar
probably buddy yeah and when all the
animal you find that sexy or not I
probably loves that I love strong you
like hard yeah I like big strong girls
like that he likes girls that are so
close to growing a dick but look at her
body right there look at her back and
look at her butt there I got no problem
yeah I I mean I I'm a fan would look
like that you have a great body I try
joking could now we train with Ben no
I'm good we'll get you in the way on
that quick we'll get you we'll get to
move around okay so you should
attractive be but there's a lot that yet
some of them I mean yeah obviously and
your line ass but they're all they're
all yeah but you know at the end of the
day I step it up and I surprise them and
they're like what the [ __ ] yeah you're
all hold on who is this person she's
pretty for sure this one of the girls
when I hunter LM prosper I knew exactly
Team USA she's she's a competitive
weightlifter like a competitive guys can
just like [ __ ] in ice baths every night
she's a real athlete
okay you know real athlete do you think
that that would be weird no really no
you don't think you guys would get
competitive no I'm not like I'm not a
computer on the same field yeah hmm I
just find out like what if she was like
taking approach oh Jesus she's a real
athlete what if she was like taking a
protein powder you didn't think this I
have to we'd have to get into her I said
fight over anything those ABS are sexy
yeah I do
you don't like that oh you're gay man
all I need is a bigger car that's what
I'm saying I think it's cool that you're
into that but look at her she's I think
it's cool you're open about it I think
she's adorable no she's pretty sure like
something super sexy about like this is
me as a I guess I'm nothing I'm trying
to be a straight man
is there something sexy about her
ambition - oh yeah like when I yeah
or now usually just sex you look at
someone who has Drive and has their own
thing is super sick like that's what I
see that's the first thing I see at her
it's like discipline we took loyalty I
like her character based on the other
bodies a competitive athlete where's Lee
look at my body and you see someone who
just like different no commitment no I
think you look like you're in ridicul
always say that I think you're working
out all the time you're lying I never
work I even worked on some heights
that's good Exodus don't care no I've
hiked want stupider yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]